struggling against the flood waters on a
self-made raft men head downstream to
higher ground
they're carrying what they've been able
to salvage
the once clear waters of the swap river
are now a filthy grey
across the floodplain of the swat valley
people are searching for anything that
they can reclaim
bit by bit they gather their precious
fines
crossing the river at its lowest and
safest points
youngsters scamper along the newly
formed banks of the river that land that
would have been in front of them has
been washed away
others can't possessions along the
river's edge in wheelbarrows
in some parts the flood waters have
receded battered buildings have
re-emerged from the torrents that
engulfed them here
the swat rose over 30 feet in just
minutes
seeing a lot of people along the river
but still quite a torrent though it has
subsided a lot indeed it was up to here
so that's a 30 feet above a normal uh
riverbed level those guys are actually
looking for wood and that comes from the
wood of houses further upstream that
have been uh washed away you see people
all over they look pretty much in shock
actually they're sort of just staring
into this this river which is nowhere
near this side as normal infrastructure
is going to be the big problem you see
here all along this section of town has
just disappeared and there were
restaurants and uh
hotels here they've gone
getting that infrastructure rebuilt is
going to take obviously a long time
there's a lot of displaced people in
this area but
culturally and variety of reasons they
actually stay in family and friends
houses rather than displacement camps
there's no displacement camps in this
section
of the valley
international aid
infrastructure rebuilding it all has to
happen but it's going to take a very
long time not least because so much of
the infrastructure has been washed away
so many roads and bridges have seemed
simply destroyed
a lone truck is being used to dump mud
from flooded houses and businesses back
into the river
it's watched on by men who just a week
ago would have been underwater
now they come to the river's edge to
just stare and think about what's
happened to this famous tourist
destination and their livelihoods
the weather is unusual
over the years have you noticed the
change in the weather
foreign the monsoon rains have been
life-changing and deadly but the season
isn't over yet
a repeat of the heavy rains in these
mountains could bring even more tragedy
to pakistan
stuart ramsey sky news in the swat
valley